>> Sean: WELCOME TO FOX NEWS.
9:00 ON THE EAST COAST, 6:00 ON
THE WEST COAST.
U.S. SUPREME COURT JUSTICE RUTH
BADER GINSBERG IS DEAD AT THE
AGE OF 87.
SHE BATTLED CANCER FOR DECADES.
I WAS FIGHTING PANCREATIC CANCER
AT THE TIME OF HER PASSING.
SHOW LEAVES A LONG LEGACY OF THE
SUPREME COURT.
SHE WAS APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT
BILL CLINTON, KNOWN AS ONE OF
THE MOST LIBERAL-LEANING JUDGES
ON THE BENCH.
JUSTICE GINSBERG HAD A
DISTINGUISHED LEGAL CAREER.
THE FIRST JEWISH WOMAN TO SERVE
ON THE HIGHEST COURT IN OUR
LAND.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS BY THE
WAY TONIGHT ARE WITH THE ENTIRE
GINSBERG FAMILY, HER COLLEAGUES
AT THE SUPREME COURT AND
EVERYBODY THAT KNEW AND LOVED
JUSTICE GINSBERG.
SOURCES ON THE GROUND HAVE SAID
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT BEEN
INFORMED OF HER DEATH PRIOR TO
GOING ON STAGE.
INTERESTINGLY, WHY THEY DID HAVE
A DEEP PHILOSOPHICAL DIVIDE,
JUSTICE GINSBERG WAS KNOWN TO
HAVE A GREAT FRIENDSHIP WITH
ANTONIN SCALIA.
THEY WERE CLOSE FRIENDS.
BY THE WAY, MY OWN FATHER DIED
FROM PANCREATIC CANCER IN A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
SHE BATTLED THIS CANCER WITH